ده نوع من استديو الرياض ينضم الينا
مستشار وزير الاعلام اليمني فهد الشرفي
اهلا بك سيد فهد اذا حتى مع حاله الانصهار
هذه بين الحرس الثوري بين الحوثي وحزب
الله العوامل التي تدفع الحوثيين اكثر
باتجاه حزب الله هل تتمثل او هل تكمن
باللغه فقط باللغه
العوامل التي ماذا
العوامل التي تدفع الحوثيين اكثر باتجاه
حزب الله من الحرس الثوري هل تكمن بشكل
اكبر في اللغه تشارك اللغه
طبعا من حيث التاسيس له اسبقيه كبيره وهو
من اقدم ربما الاجر على الايرانيه التي
كانت خارج الحدود الايرانيه ولديه باع
طويل ايضا في التعامل مع النظام الايراني
اضافه الى ان المذهب الذي يعتنقه حزب الله
هو المذهب الامامي الاثني عشري الجعفري
وهو مذهب ولائه خالص 100% وليس عليه اي
شوائب كثير من العوامل تجعل الاقدميه لحزب
الله رغم ان ربما الحوثيين في الفتره
الاخيره في التوسع والمساحه اصبحوا
يسيطرون على مساحه تفوق بعشرات المرات
المساحه التي يسيطر عليها حزب الله لكن
الحزب الله مشرفا على الحوثيين همم لهذه
العوامل وهي عوامل الاقدميه وعامل ايضا
الولائيه حيث يعتبر الايرانيون ان حسن نصر
الله
الحزب الله ولاؤهم بنسبه 100%
للثوره الايرانيه بينما الحوثيين لا زالوا
شيعه تحت التدريب لانه همم ينظر الاماميين
او الجعافره او اتباع المذهب الجعفري الى
الشيعه في انهم شيعه درجه ثانيه او شيعه
درجه ثالثه حتى انه لا يعترف لا يعترف
بامامهم الذي هو الامام زيد بن علي وفي
كتب الاماميه يقولون له لا يقولون الامام
زيد وانما زيد الشهيد هناك فروق عقائديه
كانت ايران انها لا زالت عائشه امام
الحوثي وبالتالي العام او ربما من بدايه
العشر سنوات الاخيره خضع الحوثيين
المحاوله اعاده
موضعها فكريه في محاوله لجذبهم اكثر في
التخلي عن المبادئ الزيديه اكثر من
المبادئ الاماميه الجعفريه نعم واذا
تحدثنا ايضا في الاعلام السلاح الاقوى
بحسب خامنئي هذا النموذج في ذات القالب
يمكن ل من يتابع سواء اعلام الحوثي او
اعلام حزب الله او اعلام جميع المليشيات
التي تدعمها ايران يعني يجد ان الرساله
واضحه في هذا الاعلام هذه النسخه
الاعلاميه تحديدا الحوثيه هل هناك اساليب
حكوميه لمواجهه ما تقدمها في المقابل
هو لنا الاعلام المشروع الايراني في
المنطقه اعلام متجانس ومتادم
همم
والوسائل الاعلاميه الحوثيه يشرف عليها
شخص معروف وهو من قيادات ال- همم حزب الله
وهذا الشخص موجود وكان ياتي الى صنعاء في
2013 فيها اعلاني لبناني وهذا الاعلامي
المشرف على قناه المسيره وقناه الساحات
ووسائل الاعلام الموجوده في الضاحيه
الجنوبيه وهو ايضا الذي درب اضافه الى ان
ايضا للحوثيين باع في الاعلام واشتغلوا
على الاجانب الاعلامي وكانوا يعدوا انفسهم
لان هذه همم ثورتهم او منهجهم او نهجهم
دائما
بصفه رئيسيه اوبترا راينا انهم يهتمون
الاعلام الحربي حيث بين كل خمسه اعلامي او
خمسه مقاتلين مق الاعلامي اعلام حربي يصور
في المواقع لان
مساله همم يعني تحشيد الناس قائمه على
الرساله الاعلاميه وعلى التصوير واحيانا
تصوير الدرامي يعني ان يغامر الحوثيين
باربعه خمسه يصلون الى موقع معين ويطلق
هيتابات معينه انتم لاحظتم انه اثناء
الحرب فعلى الحدود مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
الحوثيين قدموا مجموعه عالي 10 اشخاص ومع
مصور الى موقع ربما ان هذا الموقع ليس
موقعا سعوديها ورفع القنبله وقال كلمه
تحولت الى ايقونه انه وصلنا لنفسك يا
سعودي وبالتالي هذه يحولها وضحكوا على
عشرات الالاف
اصلا
شكرا جزيلا لك اتمنى استوديو الرياض
مستشار وزير الاعلام اليمني فهد الشرفي